whether you love it hate it I've never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up Douglasville
Georgia for just maybe banning pit bulls
bacon New York for pulling the plug on
the retro arcade museum officials
decided to enforce a long ignored
ordinance that bans amusement arcades
but there's only one nanny of the month
and this time it's Burrell Ellis CEO of
DeKalb County Georgia for cracking down
on organic vegetables DeKalb County man
will soon be in court for growing too
many vegetables that's Steve Miller he's
grown veggies in his garden for 15 years
but now faces about 30 grand and fines
and legal fees because the county says
he's violating zoning laws neighbors
have started calling this ongoing battle
cabbage gate Miller did get his property
rezone but code enforcement officers are
still on his case since Miller they say
was breaking the law before the rezoning
strange behavior for a place that calls
itself the greenest county in America
got me into trouble and I can't
understand why check back next month for
more examples of busybodies minding your
own business
you